Have a very optimistic view of,
of market work,
which sometime is associated to,
to Adam Smith is the view that you have
self regulation of the market and the
natural forces,
natural market forces can take care of
everything and in particular can ensure
that inequality will never increase to
such an extent that it becomes socially
and economically and politically useless
or even dangerous for that matter.
Now I think in fact,
if you,
if you reread the Adam's meets or if you
try to look at the economic developments
route eastery you see that,
you know,
you cannot expect everything from the
market.
You cannot just rely on natural forces
to solve all problems.
And I think one of the conclusion from
the history of political economy and the
history of economic growth and
inequality is that,
uh,
you need a strong public institutions in
order to put these poor,
full market forces,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the right direction where market
forces can produce a lot of innovation,
a lot of incentives for [inaudible]
entrepreneurship.
And this is very positive,
but it would be a mistake to,
to,
to rely on and count on these natural
forces to sort of self regulate a
themself.
And,
and if you look,
uh,
in in particular the period going to the
financial crises of 2007,
2008,
you have a very large concentration of
economic gains in poor,
relatively small group of the
population.
And I think everybody agrees today's as
this has contributed not only to the
stagnation of median household income,
but also to the rise of ouch all debt,
which in turn put pressure on the
financial system and probably did
contribute to fragilize the financial
system with consequences that we know in
terms of financial crises,
recession and unemployment,
which we are now starting to get out of
this.
But there has been many years of lost
growth and the lost a lot of,
uh,
social suffering because of this.
So we need a strong public institutions
in order to regulate this,
uh,
this market forces and the sometime,
there's really accessive face in these
forces.
There are cycles over history.
You know,
probably after the Great Depression
after World War Two,
people realize that market forces need
to be a strongly regulated and then
starting in the 70s and the 80s with the
radio and,
and touch our revolution.
And even more so after the fall of the
Soviet Union,
we entered in the 1990s and 2000 in a
new cycle of sometime unlimited face
into self regulation of markets.
And to a large extent we are still in
this phase and a,
and I sing the reaction to policy
reaction to the financial crisis of 2007
2008 has been too limited so far.
And this could happen again.
You know,
we've asked a lot to our central banks
in the US,
in Europe and of course it's easy to
print a billions of dollars or billions
of euros to avoid complete bankruptcy of
the financial system,
which is what happened in the 1930s and
which and dinner peanut complete
catastrophe.
So it's,
you know,
it's better to avoid that.
But at the same time,
printing money is not enough to solve
the structural problem that we need to
sell.
So,
you know,
the good news is that we avoided the
complete bankruptcy and complete
depression.
But the bad news is that we did not
really serve the structural problems,
which might in the future create a new
new crisis.
Okay.